whoa hello Greg Alba here Andrew here
Andrew here from the movie source
channel brought in here today as he is a
Batman enthusiast Suicide Squad official
comic-con trailer I've seen a lot of
Suicide Squad videos lately I'm going to
watch this because everyone's really
requesting that we check this out holy
okay here's to honor
among thieves we almost pulled it off
despite what everybody thought
they're gonna blame us for the whole
thing where the patsies don't forget
mm-hmm we're the bad guys
the stories of Samson leveling a temple
with a single push
see weapons of mass destruction named
Goliath oh the next war will be fought
with these metahumans please don't
ours or theirs
trash ice no stand down made up huh that
guy's soup that must be crazy this is
the deal you're going somewhere very bad
look at the pretty white to do something
that will get skilled you might want to
work on your team motivation thing here
to Phil Jackson yeah he's like the gold
standard ok triangle [ __ ]
my father look here boy toys we're going
to the swirling ring of trash in the sky
they walk in the park
easy peasy don't make me shoot you
biggest boston I've been in trillest
I'm a bigger problem
Romeo in Cannes
guess who my back where she came feather
in my chair
sucker fight enough footage please stop
with the footage stop I started to
figure out how this movie my play out
now before I did it I'm starting to
piece together some stuff could be
totally wrong movie comes out in like
just a week or two before the Suicide
Squad gets a sample Viola Davis is going
to talk to important people gonna be
like me to assemble the squad people
that we can blame it on right please do
a montage you see the collection of the
the characters Ike Barinholtz the guard
I feel like he's the one guarding Harley
Quinn mm-hmm like one of the main people
in charge of guarding Harley Quinn I
think that's why Joker is antagonizing
him later and saying like he's gonna
like [ __ ] him up because it looks like
Ike Barinholtz and he's like in a suit
and stuff so it might be one of those
corrupted kind of guards those guys he
like you know takes money from criminals
and so now he rocks the nice suits and
gets all greedy and stuff so he becomes
a bad guy that Joker wants to take down
because he probably abused Harley in
some way just the big assumption after
they get in their helicopter the Suicide
Squad team they gate taking down Suicide
Squad has to fight their way out and
then they're having that moment in the
building where they're like drinking and
the Will Smith is like hey they're gonna
blame it all on us and then Joker
eventually shows up yeah that's kind of
what I've gathered so far it's pretty
good theory I definitely have a few
things in my mind that I think are gonna
happen but like you said what I'm hoping
for when we see this movie is I want to
be surprised obviously but the thing I'm
really looking most forward to is I like
the chemistry between all the the main
Suicide Squad so far I mean just it
really looks like it's very organic
between all them they look like even
though they just kind of got together at
the last second they really do look like
I said an organic team and just looks
like they're gonna be a lot of fun to be
around even though we're in like I said
a more serious dark take on this it
looks like again there are also going to
be some comedic elements even though
it's a more serious dark take on this
kind of a film but I gotta say - one big
thing I'm noticing in all these trailers
is Slipknot is like not
anything he's in like one little clip on
everything clearly he's gonna die first
right away assuming through the chip
that they were putting a squadron yes
he's gonna try to escape and then when
his brains blow out are all the other
squad members I'm like yeah we're not
gonna try to escape we will do exactly
what Viola Davis or Amanda Waller is
expecting us to do it's just funny how
he's not anything yeah it's true the
more I see of Jai Courtney the more I
really liking what he's doing absolutely
right because Jack Courtney man like
he's one of those actors who I think
hasn't taken himself very seriously
too stale too serious I really feel like
he's letting loose here and lenguages
thing about the humor it's like these
characters are very dark characters so
there's gonna be some really dark humor
which I like Will Smith though as
Deadshot
still seems like Will Smith as Deadshot
Ian's unlikely on this it's hard for me
to just go Will Smith it's just doing a
really cool role his delivery his
dialogue everything a bomb is still
seems very Wolfe Smith reminiscing which
might not be a bad thing it could aid
the film he is Top Billing actor so I'm
assuming he is gonna be the primary lead
but I'm like way more interested in
every other year Gervais is dead shot at
this point Margot Robbie looks like
she's gonna kill it man despite whatever
you want your Harley Quinn
interpretation to be if you watch other
margot robbie movies and you see just
footage from this you're like kids I
don't see margot robbie in this role at
all like this is just that this is a
different person right now and that's
all i really wanted so whatever
interpretation she gives I'm sure it's
gonna be a kick-ass job I saw a clip the
other day to where she was calling Joker
pudding in the purple Lamborghini and
literally watch I'm like this is the
animated series come to life like it's -
it J yeah their chemistry - between
Jared Leto and Margaret I'm so
fascinated to see that because I've been
waiting since 1992 since we first got
Harley Quinn in the animated series
I believe the episode was Joker's favor
I believe though this is the first
episode or I wanted to see this
character on screen and ever since I saw
wolf of wallstreet watching Margot
Robbie that woman needs to play Harley
Quinn finally get over a week and a half
to away or so I'm beyond ecstatic to see
what she does with this role because
like you said I'm not going to compare
her to Heath Ledger but just from the
perspective of I don't see Heath Ledger
where is he
I don't see him anywhere it's the same
thing with Margot Robbie obviously I'm
gonna judge her after we see the film of
course but just from all the trailers
ago I'm like I don't see Margot Robbie
anywhere this is Harley Quinn it's not
just a Harley went from the animators
but this is Harley Quinn just from all
the everything she's saying the makeup
the way she's talking the way she's
moving it's Harley Quinn what I'm a
little concerned about too is the Joker
story to be honest okay cuz the Joker
I feel like Jerr Leto is gonna nail the
role but the story itself it seems like
the Joker story's a totally separate
thing going on from everything else
that's going on like yeah it seems like
a subplot that could tie in and overall
and make the biggest difference by the
end of the film but I'm worried that
it's gonna be like well this is
something so separate it doesn't
strongly connect as we hope it would but
for then again Harley Quinn is part of
the main members of the Suicide Squad
and I like that they're not showing us
the Joker story yeah we don't know what
the hell the Joker's up to we don't know
exactly what he's doing we've just got
in like brief images some moments really
like that's probably how Harley Quinn
became Harley Quinn again I'm just
speculating what I can see happening
here is common as the main bad guy
believe he's playing master P the tattoo
I don't know who he's playing I wouldn't
be shocked if he tries to have joke or
help him now that he sees the Suicide
Squad is like messing up his that whole
army of goons that we saw in the trailer
and then Joker he doesn't want to team
up a partner then when he's going to
betray you in backstab you as we clearly
saw I know this is a different Joker but
just incarnations we've seen a Joker he
back stabs betrays his uh his co-workers
as you saw in the Dark Knight in the
bank-robbery scene and other iterations
of the Joker so we're just what's up for
himself even in the cartoons in the
comics out of Harley Quinn he like Dix
over Hartley and also uh yeah that's one
my favorite part they're related
Harley's always falling for mr. J and
falls in love with him and then gets
manipulated by him if he has to be lab
manager fuel-efficiency how's that when
they fight and then they make up and
it's like a really abusive relationship
I can't wait to see their chemistry on
screaming I think that's talented as
Margot Robbie and Jared Leto are I feel
like they would have dynamic chemistry
working together in these roles and I
wonder if Margot Robbie was able to
study a little bit of Jer
letõs interpretation before doing
Harlequin since the character of Harley
Quinn is strongly derived from like
being a female alias of the Joker that I
wonder if like Margot Robbie did have
time to like study a little bit of Jared
Leto first laughing wants a David Ayer
as writer and director of this David
Ayers films I find to be very hit and
miss when his writing career really
became known it was your training day
but then you know you got films like
streaking sinan you have like dark blue
but then and of watch comes out and
despite how you feel I don't know
sabotage with Schwarzenegger I
personally liked it but I understand why
people had problems with it yeah I mean
I love Arnold I liked it at first but
then I couldn't even finish later and
then fury comes out so you know like
every once in a while he does a good
harsh times that I could I thought that
was kind of annoying so I've seen most
of his photo this is his territory that
he could do I hope a Warner Brothers
didn't tie him down to having to really
tie all this and some people are bummed
out that they ruined that Batman's in
the film I think it's that big of a deal
so that most of these films are Batman's
direct villains that it doesn't bother
me
hopefully David Ayer this is one of his
hits instead of one of his misses so I'm
a big David Ayer fan as well from what
I've heard in interviews he has a deep
respect for these characters I don't
know if he said Marvel sucks or somebody
says like DC villains are the best or
which he's got a point DC villains are
yeah credible and obviously spider-man's
got amazing films with Marvel but either
way David Ayer really understands these
characters just from the interviews I've
seen and it looks like he has a love and
respect for these characters I'm very
interested in taking this man
understands violence and action and he
knows how to shoot it just from that
perspective I'm very you know curious
and I gotta say one other thing I'm
liking from all these shows I love the
color saturation and all these it looks
like a very colorful film rather than
you know
dharak looks like it's well shot so from
david ayers perspective i'm really
excited and it looks great about the
trailers like i would guess this is an
r-rated fellow yeah I mean I know it I
know it's pg-13 but they probably got
Nolan it looking ready yeah it looks
dark it looks menacing it looks violent
like it looks like something that looks
sinister so yeah I'm hoping though real
like I know they have them this movie
has to be good but maybe one day when
the sequel comes up maybe it'll be rated
or you know cuz I mean ya might be on
board Wolverine with Marvel both Fox
actually Wolverine 3 is confirmed to be
reality and with the ultimate edition of
Batman V Superman dated our Deadpool
I feel like r-rated comic book movies
are a thing that's going to be around a
lot more with these bigger kind of
stories and Suicide Squad if it is done
right and loved by the majority of
people this could be the thing that
truly makes DC films stand out most a
little bit because everyone knows that
with Marvel they're villains have been a
little bit weak and a little bit
lackluster excluding a few and excluding
some of the television characters with
terms of movies you know this summer
Cinematic Universe Suicide Squad is
promoting their villains of which is
going to be interesting to see how they
handle these characters after Suicide
Squad at the end of day they're gonna be
the protagonist of this story when
they're gonna be the antagonist of like
a future DC movies I'm getting I'm gonna
see how that how that really like makes
me feel how that plays out so I'm
interested to see what direction this
goes down definitely one last thing
before we go I did notice in that
trailer we saw it said Belle Reve where
they were were the the prisoners were in
before like a man ships him at all I
thought they were in Arkham Asylum so
that was interesting that they said they
were in Belle Reve because I believe
Belle Reve is in Metropolis and that's
like you know Superman's Arkham Asylum
so I thought that was interesting to see
if that's where they're being in a sense
qualm yeah like before they're before
they're putting the chips in and Amanda
takes them because I thought they were
all in our yeah she knows Arkham old
yeah it said Belle Reve in the trill and
must have reshare I saw Belle Reve in
the trailer so very cool
well guys next time you hear is talking
about Suicide Squad it'll be because we
saw the actual movie if you're new to
this channel subscribe yay
andrew is from the movie source channel
check them out yay follow us on our
social networks yay we've talked for a
long time